vamos a trabajar con todo lo que hemos
aprendido acerca de las potencias
negativas y para esto este ejemplo me
encanta dice categoriza el valor de cada
expresión exponencial y bueno nos dicen
que tomemos cada uno de estos por
ejemplo este lo podremos poner en un
valor que sea menor que menos 1 entre
menos uno y cero y entre cero y uno y
bueno vamos a hacer eso para cada uno de
estos y encontrar a cuál de estos
conjuntos pertenece pero para eso vamos
a sacar nuestras notas ok los tengo aquí
ya copie aquí la parte que nos importa
el problema y vamos a trabajar con cada
uno de estos para ver a qué llegamos y
dice bueno antes antes de ver en dónde
en qué conjunto está cada uno de ellos
qué te parece si tenemos una recta
numérica voy a hacer una recta numérica
por aquí
ok estadismo recta numérica y vamos a
ver de qué intervalos estoy hablando
estoy hablando del intervalo que sea
menor que menos 1 así que si por aquí
está el menos 1
y vamos a poner que por aquí está el 0
ok y que por aquí por aquí está el 1
ok y yo quiero categorizarlos en todos
los números que sean menores que menos 1
menores que menos 1 este me va a
representar justo a todos los números
que son negativos pero que son menores
que menos 1 son todos estos de aquí
todos estos son el primer conjunto ahora
también tengo los números que estén
entre menos uno y cero y para eso voy a
tomar este color todos los números que
estén entre menos uno y cero y déjame
ponerlo aquí con un asterisco van a ser
justo estos de aquí los que están aquí
van a pertenecer a este conjunto y por
último déjenme tomar este color para
hablar los números que están entre 0 y 1
entre 0 y 1 es decir todos los que van a
estar justo por aquí estos son los
números que van a estar entre 0 y 1 y
cada uno de estos tiene que caer en una
de estas tres categorías y solamente en
una así que vamos a empezar con el
primero que dice 4 elevado a la menos 4
al menos 4 y lo primero que yo pienso
cuando veo un exponente negativo es que
este número es el recíproco de 4 elevado
a la 4 o de otra manera este número lo
podemos pensar y como lo hemos visto
bastante en los vídeos pasados como uno
recuerda que pongo un 1 abajo del 1
dividiendo voy a poner 4 elevado a la
misma potencia solamente que positiva 4
a la 4 y quiero que te des cuenta que es
lo que pasa con este número en primer
lugar este es un número positivo no es
un número negativo aunque teníamos una
potencia negativa recuerda que las
potencias negativas no afectan el signo
de mi base y ahora lo que quiero también
que veas es que 4 elevado a la 4 es un
número muy grande es como 256 no importa
cuánto sea 4 elevado a la 4 lo que sí
importa y lo que quiero que veas es que
1 entre un número muy grande pues es un
número muy pequeño
entre 4 a 4 es un número muy pequeño y
positivo y por lo tanto podemos decir
que está entre 0 y 1 por aquí va a estar
1 entre 4 a la 4 entonces bueno ya
sabemos que este de que esté aquí va a
ir a dar a los números que están entre 0
y 1 a los números que están entre 0 y 1
va a ir para acá ok vamos a trabajar con
el segundo que dice menos 4 elevado al
cubo menos 4 elevado al cubo y bueno en
este caso lo primero que pienso es que
menos 4 elevado al cubo es exactamente
lo mismo que menos 4 x menos 4 por a
menos 4 y bueno esto lo podemos
representar de la siguiente manera esto
es lo mismo que menos 1 por 4 y esto a
su vez por menos 1 y esto a su vez por 4
y después otra vez por menos 1 por 4 y
lo estoy escribiendo de esta manera
porque quiero que te des cuenta que aquí
tengo 1
tres veces menos uno multiplicándose es
decir que esto es lo mismo que menos uno
elevado al cubo ok y esto a su vez por
cuatro por cuatro por cuatro es decir
por cuatro elevado al cubo ahora menos
uno elevado al cubo es exactamente lo
mismo que menos uno esto es lo mismo que
menos menos el signo se conserva aquí
voy a poner cuatro elevado al cubo y
bueno tú también lo podrías visualizar
exactamente igual desde aquí arriba esto
es exactamente lo mismo que menos x
menos más x menos menos 4 x 4 x 4 es 4
al cubo y lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que este este número 4 elevado
al cubo si solamente nos fijamos en esta
parte de aquí déjame cambiar el color
solamente nos fijamos en nuestra parte
de aquí 4 elevado al cubo su número muy
grande 4 elevado a los cubos como 64 y
ahora si nosotros multiplicamos por
menos voy a encontrar la versión
negativa de 4 elevado al cubo por lo
tanto si 4 elevado al cubo es un número
muy grande
cuando lo multiplicó por menos me va a
dar un número muy negativo o dicho de
otra manera menos 4 elevado al cubo es
un número que está entre los números que
son menores que menos 1 es un número muy
negativo y por lo tanto ya tenemos la
respuesta de este menos 4 elevado al
cubo es un número que va a ir justo aquí
en los números que son menores que menos
ok pues vamos a trabajar con el
siguiente tengo menos 4 elevado a la
menos cuatro lo voy a poner por aquí
menos 4 esto a su vez elevado a la menos
4 y bueno recuerda que aquí tenemos una
potencia negativa entonces lo primero
que pensamos cuando tenemos una potencia
negativa es el recíproco o en nuestras
fórmulas que nosotros nos hemos
aprendido en la ley de los exponentes
que me dice que esto es lo mismo que 1
entre menos 4 menos 4 elevado a la
cuarta potencia
ahora lo que quiero que veas es que
menos 4 elevado a la cuarta potencia lo
puedo desarrollar justo como está aquí
menos 4 elevado al cubo solamente que
por una vez más pero al final llegamos a
menos 1 elevado al cubo por 4 elevado al
cubo así que esto esto siguiendo el
mismo patrón es uno entre a menos 1
elevado a la cuarta potencia por 4
elevado a la cuarta potencia y porque lo
escribo así porque menos 1 elevado a la
cuarta potencia es menos x menos más por
menos menos menos más es un número
positivo es 1 de hecho entonces esto es
lo mismo que 1 entre 4 elevado a la 4 y
1 entre 4 elevado a la 4 es un número
que ya sabemos dónde estaba es justo
este de aquí y nosotros concluimos que
este número que estaba aquí es un número
que está entre 0 y 1 entre 0 y 1 y por
lo tanto menos 4 elevado al menos 4
también es un número que está entre 0 y
1 porque es de hecho exactamente lo
mismo que 1 entre 4 elevado
entonces estoy aquí estoy aquí voy a
concluir que es un número que está entre
por acá entre 0 y 1
de lujo ok vamos con este de aquí vamos
a cambiar de color y voy a trabajar con
este color dice a menos 4 elevado a la
menos 5 lo voy a poner aquí menos 4
elevado a la menos 5 y tengo una
potencia negativa entonces lo primero
que voy a hacer es poner uno entre menos
4 menos 4 elevado a la quinta potencia
es decir la versión positiva de menos 5
y bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
uno entre y siguiendo el mismo patrón
que tenemos aquí arriba aunque menos 1
elevado a la quinta por 4 elevado a la
quinta es una forma de verlo o no
podemos ver también como que aquí
tenemos cinco veces multiplicados el
signo menos y entonces esto me va a dar
un número negativo esto es lo mismo que
menos
entre 4 elevado a la quinta potencia
ahora quiero que te des cuenta de algo
si yo me fijo aquí en 1 entre 4 a las 5
este de aquí por la misma razón que 1
entre 4 a la 4 es un número que está
entre 0 y 1 1 entre 4 las 5 también es
un número que está entre 0 y 1 de hecho
su número más pequeño que estoy acá
arriba sin embargo aquí tengo a este
número que es pequeño es decir que está
entre 0 y 1 pero su versión negativa y
su versión negativa va a ser un número
que está entre menos uno y cero lo único
que sé siendo tomar un número de aquí y
volverlo negativo y entonces lo paso
para acá entonces en este caso 1 entre 4
a las 5 negativo es un número que está
entre menos uno y cero la versión
negativa de un número muy pequeño por lo
tanto a este de aquí déjame cambiar el
color este de aquí va a ser un número
que está entre menos uno y cero ok y
vamos a pensar en este último de aquí
tengo menos 4 elevado a la quinta
4 elevado a la quinta esto es
exactamente lo mismo que menos 1 elevado
a la quinta por 4 elevado a la quinta
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que
menos menos 1 por menos 1 por menos 1
por menos 1 por menos 1 es un número
negativo por 4 elevado a la quinta y
bueno 4 elevado a la quinta es un número
muy grande y si yo tengo un número muy
grande por subversión negativa pues es
un número menor que menos 1 es un número
muy negativo entonces de igual manera
voy a concluir que este de aquí estoy
aquí es un número que es menor que menos
1 va a ir justo aquí ok y ya tengo la
solución de estos cinco ejercicios así
que vamos a acomodar los y espero que
tenga una buena memoria para recordar
dónde va cada uno y regresemos aquí a la
página a la página de khan academy tengo
esta página aquí dice categoriza el
valor de cada expresión exponencial 4
elevado a la menos 4 bueno pues esto
quedamos que es el recíproco de 4
a 4 por lo tanto es lo mismo que 1 entre
4 elevado a la 4 que es un número que
está entre 0 y 1 ok
menos 4 elevado al cubo bueno este es el
nota que es un número menor que menos 1
porque tengo menos 4 por lo menos 4 x
menos 4 un número muy negativo por lo
tanto es un número menor que menos 1 y
este también era un número menor que
menos 1 así que vamos a acomodar lo
justo ahorita también aquí menos 4
elevado a la menos 4 o recuerda este
ejercicio esto es lo mismo que uno entre
menos 4 elevado a la 4 ya habíamos
concluido que es exactamente lo mismo
que 4 elevado a la menos 4 que estaba
justo acá abajo entonces lo voy a poner
aquí ok y por último tengo menos 4
elevado a la menos 5 y este era el que
estaba entre menos uno y cero porque
esto es lo mismo que uno entre menos
cuatro elevado a la quinta potencia ok
perfecto y ahora si ya tengo cada una de
las expresiones categorizadas y vamos a
comprobar la respuesta vamos
respuesta y perfecto ya tenemos la
respuesta y estamos bien por lo tanto es
todo por este vídeo hasta la próxima